hey guys its benefits of a G from GE
tracker and in this video I'm going to
talk to you guys how to spot mini
short-term south imploding bubbles now
if you don't know the bubble means all
it is really is an item being overvalued
you know when an item starts rising in
value too quickly and there's no reason
for it that's starting to create a
bubble and it's going to pop meaning
that price is going to start crashing
pretty soon but you may not know how
much that item will crash this is all
about just spotting those crashes before
they happen so you can get a pair for
that and make sure you can you know get
away from that item before you face any
losses or make sure not paint you much
so in the previous video you guys might
have noticed that I was flipping
settlements late and I was buying them
from around like 135,000 each and
selling them back for maybe around
200,000 now even though I stop flipping
that item after the video I still wanted
to watch it and I noticed there was a
huge spike here on the graph now if you
don't know the red line means where
people are willing to sell this item for
and blue line means where people willing
to buy this item at now if you log in to
your g tracker account and you don't see
this on the graph all you have to do is
click the split graph and then you'll
see the two lines now you'll also notice
there's a huge gap between the red and
blue line okay and instantly that's a
red flag for me if I start seeing the
price skyrocketing but people aren't
willing to pay that much and there's
nothing bent in game like there's no
updates in game that would make that
would make this price rise whatsoever
that's telling me that this item is
basically being merged like people maybe
just someone out there has ten accounts
and he who's been hoarding up all these
items and then he's just trying to flip
him for
insanely high amount you know whatever
the reason to me when I see something
like this I know it's a thin bubble and
pretty soon it's going to pop OH if you
look at this table now it's not going to
look like that this was this was the day
after I released the previous video and
then this is where the huge bike came in
but if i look at the de Graaff after
that days video you'll see that someone
bought this item for you know 500,000
and I was trying to flip it for 200,000
then we'll look at the weekly graph and
you'll see you know as I was saying
earlier that this item was being merged
that people were trying to sell this at
a higher cost and then eventually
someone not okay this is where it should
be sold at so then the offers started
coming in for people who maybe aren't
aware of what the true value is for that
and then we have let me have that graph
again okay so why don't we look
currently where this graph stands to see
if I was right about this being a bubble
and then this decreasing because right
now this is showing me that this is
going to increase or this is increasing
to 300,000 and it looks like it's going
up I don't know maybe I'm a newbie and I
don't know anything about merging but
the graph looks like it's going up so
why don't we look to see what's
happening okay so after the little bump
happened it's starting to crash just
like I said
because it was nothing in game telling
this item or there was nothing in game
given this item any more value than it
already had and when you see gaps like
that when you see gaps like this on the
chart you're going to want to be careful
you're going to want to pay attention to
the weekly graphs and pay attention to
see if there's any spikes like this
because if you see spike like this then
you're going to want to start putting
offers at a lower amount because right
now this item settling about 160,000 and
it looks like it's being flatlined so
even so earlier when I release the video
of me flipping this this this chart was
up and down the whole way through but
now it's completely flat line because
the item crashed merchants created a
bubble for this and so yeah that's what
happened and that three on a beta do
that's how you spot a mini short-term
bubble and if you guys like this video
you guys have any other suggestions for
any type of videos that you guys want to
see you know leave a comment down below
be sure to subscribe and until next time